this video was voted for by patrons of
questions for science at some point in
time everyone is over Eden at least once
it's just something that people do and
as long as you don't make it a habit
[Music]
it's not that bad however when you
overeat bad things do happen to your
body but first let's get on the same
page of what is defined as overeating
according to Wikipedia overeating or
hyperphagia is defined as excess food
consumed in relation to the energy that
an organism expense leading to weight
gain and often obesity it may be
regarded as disorder and can be a
symptom of binge eating disorder bulimia
nervosa well how about a definition
that's less clinical relative to
physical manifestations overeating is
defined as consuming a volume of food
that is more than 1 liter which is the
fill volume for the stomach more
specifically if after a meal you have
nausea abdominal discomfort and extreme
fatigue
you've probably over eaten so what
happens to your body when you overeat
firstly the stretching of a stomach
stimulates the vagus nerve which runs
from the brain down to the stomach the
high amount of stretching in the gut
sends a signal to your brain to tell you
that you've hit capacity this triggers
the brain to stimulate a painful
sensation of tissue stretching in the
stomach to make sure you stop eating one
way people unintentionally overeat is by
eating too fast
if you eat too quickly you can actually
bypass the stretch mechanism by filling
the stomach with food before it has time
to expand causing you to overeat and
then feel a delayed reaction of being
full the stomach by default holds one
liter of food but because the organ
tissue can stretch it's volume can
increase up to 3 liters with the stomach
volume now being 2 to 3 times larger it
presses up against your abdominal organs
which are packed together like sardines
making the infamous food baby your
stomach also pushes on the diaphragm
reducing the expansion volume of your
lungs which is why you have shallow
breaths after you overeat next your
expanded stomach and food contents put
pressure on a piece of circular muscle
called the cardiac sphincter which sits
between the esophagus in the opening of
the stomach the job of the cardiac
sphincter is like every other fainter in
the body to act as a natural body
passage like here here and here
but that one's not for food it also
constricts the
opening of the stomach to prevent
backflow food into the esophagus the
expanded stomach stretches the sphincter
making it open which is why you feel
nauseous when you overeat the stomach
has a reflux that prevents you from
eating so much that you rupture it if
you were to eat more than the stomach
could physically hold the food contents
would be forced past the cardiac
sphincter and into your esophagus once
here the stomach activates a purging
reflex that makes you vomit the contents
so you don't damage the organ however
with overeating you stop just as a
cardiac sphincter is getting stretched
this causes the reflux to be irritated
putting you in a constant halfway point
between nausea and feeling full
while digesting the parietal cells in
the stomach lumen released gastric acid
composed of hydrochloric acid potassium
chloride and sodium chloride normally
this is a harmless process gastric acid
is released food is broken down and is
then sent to the small intestine no
problem however because your stomach is
now 2 to 3 times overfilled the body has
to produce a higher volume of gastric
acid to digest the food add to the fact
that your cardiac sphincter is now
partially open the higher volume of
gastric acid flows into your esophagus
causing heartburn if your meal was high
in fat like chicken wings or
cheeseburger the digestion will take
even longer as fats require the most
time to be broken down finally a very
large amount of digested food has to be
passed through your intestines more food
means more weight which means more work
for your intestinal tract your heart
rate increases to divert extra blood
from the rest of your body to stimulate
compression of the intestines to carry
the food to your colon
once digested food is in the intestines
the pancreas secretes higher amounts of
amylase protease in lipase enzymes to
further break down carbohydrates protein
and fat in your intestines this
diversion of blood from your muscles and
extra enzyme production requires large
amounts of energy causing extreme
fatigue which is why you feel so tired
after you overeat
luckily once food leaves a stomach it
shrinks back to its normal resting
volume of 73 milliliters however
consistent overeating will lead to
weight gain as the excess calories that
are not burned off are stored as fat a
really good way to prevent yourself from
overeating is to eat slower the best
meal to achieve this is soup because it
takes longer to eat a bowl of soup than
it does a slice of pizza or chew
Birger by the time you finished the soup
your brain has had time to register that
your stomach has expanded instead of
over filling before it expands and click
the bell to subscribe you know
[Music]
[Music]